arranca con algo fuerte con algo que
dijeron los chicos que organizan nunca
hable en público y dije algo fuerte que
hago me pongo en pelotas
no sé cómo la ven
ok ya entendí pero miren si me muero
ahora me da un ataque de pánico escénico
flaqueó se imagina en el escándalo
mostrar la muerte es de peor gusto que
mostrar las partes también la tenemos
asumida hablamos de ella con naturalidad
hasta podemos [ __ ] con eso pero
mientras sea algo que está allá que
algún día algo hipotético cuando estás
cerca la cosa cambia andamos en wood y
está de pie hablamos en susurros nos
ponemos serio graves o directamente nos
hacemos los boludos y miramos para otro
lado tratar todavía bien vas a ver
justo ahí cuando se nos viene encima que
la enfrentaremos que la tenemos que
enfrentar justo ahí la muerte de su
voluntad o de eso inhalar no el de
ponerse en pelotas lástima sino sobre ya
saben
y en calidad de que dan a todos no soy y
tengo una funeraria me contacto con la
muerte de este lado el mostrador como
simple usuario soy viudo soy el vídeo de
maria vaqué si no la conocen después la
pueden buscar ojo no se confunda van a
encontrar una recta o pre linda que está
buenísima pero después está la otra
maría vázquez que era una modelo esa no
la que dije primero una mina que ya no
notaría precisamente por su atrevimiento
de tener una muerte y pública hace un
par de años mari en perfecto estado de
salud vida sana corría estaba entrenando
para la maratón madre reciente un nene
de dos y de un día para el otro cáncer
fulminante
cómo se maneja una situación así como te
sale no está preparado no hay manual les
cuento cómo nos sale a nosotros mar y
apenas se despierta la anestesia lo
primero que hace como la dejaban hablar
escribe contarme todo todo subrayado dos
veces le conté se abrieron era cáncer
nomás sacar un tumor ovarios útero
endometrio todo se cerraron y vas a
quimio en esa hora fatal de cara a su
cruel destino recién abierta y vaciada
por dentro que respondió
ahora sí que soy hueca
era la clase de mina que en una
situación así te hacia un chiste por eso
yo un par de días después cuando llegó
el momento de hablar se lo dije mar y
esto es así y te vas a morir la mano
viene a que te morís de una no había una
mejor manera de decírselo a ella
y la conversación que vi no hay tremenda
no tanto por esa ni por mí como por ni
por nuestro hijo para terminar le dije
mira cuando sea un poco más grande y
entienda y lo voy a sufrir se hace lo
que voy a hacer le digo hijo yo sé que
esto es muy duro ahora pero confío en
papá dentro de unos años con el chamuyo
el huerfanito va a sacar char dando
hijos
me venía escuchando toda compungida y se
tuvo agarrar la panza para que no le
salte el punto de la risa
yo no tenía que pelear profundidades
asistenciales para estar a su altura
tenía que lanzar chistes se volvió un
patrón porque a partir de ahí fue una
asociación de malas noticias que siempre
me llegaban primero a mí y en el acto
como un muro se alzaba entre los dos que
nos ponía el universo paralelo yo acá en
el de los vivos es allá en el de los
morituri de pronto éramos dos extraños
el horror pero duraba hasta que ponía
las cartas sobre la mesa y ahí esa
amenaza oscura e innombrable bajaba a
hacerlo en nuestra nueva realidad a ver
cómo la pilote amos y hablando ese muro
empezaba a tambalearse a ya crujir y
cuando por fin llegaba el chiste lo
terminaba de tirar abajo porque no era
para distender el humor era su manera de
reafirmarse de decir acá estoy sigo
siendo la tierra que siempre se acabó de
la risa de todo hasta de mí misma sigo
siendo yo tienen la risa ya estábamos
otra vez juntos así fue que en casa
empezó a reinar algo que una de las
soldadas las soldadas son las amigas de
mar y una docena de pelotas geniales que
tuvieron ahí
firme como rocas una de ellas kit
bautizó esta práctica las amo tumor
negro el tumor negro en casa tubo azul
no dejamos marino dejó chiste macabro si
no se retira los suyos y así a fuerza de
tumor negro y de como decía ella emoción
amor y gilada nos regaló y esto lo hablé
con todo lo que tuvimos ahí y todos
sentimos lo mismo nos regale una fiesta
despedida no fue otra cosa hasta el
final es hasta el velorio que lo
organizaron las soldadas con ellas yo
las vi juntas armando la lista de pot y
fai o poniendo una foto de ella en
bikini en un portal retrato de animal
print para que fuera arriba del cajón
pero parecía que estaban armando un
cumpleaños la boluda no un funeral
fueron siete meses de surrealismo en un
clima de joda que generaba ella y que
los demás no teníamos que ir turnando
para salir un rato llorar como hijo de
[ __ ] sacarnos las lágrimas y volver a
seguir riéndonos con ella fácil y saber
nada demasiado sorprendente para los que
la conocíamos no esperábamos otra cosa
lo que sí nos podíamos prever es que
todo esto maría era twitter a nadie
perfecto y ya tenía miles de seguidores
cuando se enfermó y después siguió como
venía nada más que ahora entre sus temas
estaba en la enfermedad la muerte su
enfermedad su muerte habló de ella como
hablaba de todo impía mordaz pero
lamento será victimización a puro tumor
negro y eso centro idealizar vi realizar
y terminó armando tal revuelo que le
llevó a la tapa de los diarios y a la
tele o sea que además de todo el
surrealismo que ya veníamos viviendo
ahora encima la fama es joda esto ya fue
todo qué más puede pasar
qué más puede pasar
mari que se pasó la vida escribiendo y
dibujando le encantaba durante esos
siete meses culminó su obra cumbre
nuestros tesoros para dejarle algo al
nene le escribió le dibujó un cuaderno
y dejarlo en la mano nada más de parte
porque sabes lo que es pero adentro es
lo más gracioso y divertido amoroso
lleno de vida una cosa tan linda tan
golosa le salió que seis meses después
por iniciativa de un par de las soldadas
que son escritoras con el aval de marín
los movieron editoriales y lo publicó
planeta el cuaderno de nippur para mí
fue una alegría pensar que algún día ni
puro va a poder decir que su cuaderno
aquella vez también fue el libro que
lindo no
se agotó en una semana best-seller otra
vez tapa de diarios otra vez la tele me
pasaron por todo local de ale me llaman
donde todas las radios y se agotó la
segunda y la tercera va por la cuarta
edición acaba de salir en españa' ahora
va a salir en méxico centro y
norteamérica y todo esto ya es un
delirio que yo no entiendo más nada
pero me encanta por nippur porque como
digo siempre sé que va a ser huérfano
que sea huérfano de madre legendaria
y lo es porque te hija de [ __ ] en su
agonía en vez de irse apagando como una
vela estalló como una supernova de yo
como nunca
haciendo que exactamente cuál fue su
proeza a ver
vio venir la muerte se [ __ ] en la pata
como cualquiera pero les salió
exprimirlo le quedará al máximo siendo
ella misma punto porque hay algo en el
fondo tan simple termina generando tanto
quilombo
porque en su caso ser ella misma implicó
cagarse en la solemnidad y romper el
tabú y eso no se hace no es la única hay
gente que se me acerca y me cuenta caso
parecido pero la inmensa mayoría me
manifiesta asombro admiración no sabía
que alguien se puede morir así me dicen
el decoro evitar el tema se hace lo
boludos esa es la norma si se me permite
en una pequeña teoría que tengo no
estando una cuestión de negación como un
problema de comunicación tan boludo no
somos nos damos cuenta lo que pasa lo
que cuesta es hablar les entiendo te
sentís el enviado de la parca y [ __ ]
pero ella con su actitud no te deja otro
remedio y menos mal menos mal porque
sirvió
de consuelo me encantaría decirle que sí
que sirve de consuelo pero les estaría
mintiendo esto es una [ __ ]
maricel o te perdonan y burn y porcel a
perder y eso es un puñal clavado acá con
solo nadie pero la crudeza haberle
cerrado la puerta a la falsedad de
reconfortante se le abrió la verdad es
que si no no nos habríamos dicho marín
murió en paz
marín murió sintiéndose re rodeada de
amor
marín
según yo inmensamente triste de que se
le va a perder any pour pero mucho más
que eso contenta de que primero lo tuvo
a tiempo antes de y se murió convencida
de que ningún y yo vamos a saber salir
adelante vamos a hacer las cosas bien y
como lo hace todo eso porque me lo dijo
saben lo que vale ahora mismo al
cuaderno ahora le doy un inculcar al
pibe que el amor infinito de la mamá no
caduca con la muerte la trasciende lo
tiene que acompañar toda la vida es para
siempre la herramienta insuperable que
me dejó para cumplir esa misión no había
existido seguro hemos jugador que iba a
salir todo bien no lo haría escrito
a mí
la vi sufrir horrores que la veis morir
no me quedo eso porque la otra vez o de
punta a punta sin dejar de reírse aquí
van a quedar sino la risa la risa no le
quita nada al dolor es al revés le suma
le agrega una dimensión te lo pone en
perspectiva te asegura que no soy tan
importante que tu tragedia no es la
única ni la peor y que nunca deja de ser
también comedia cuando me acecha el
fantasma de la autocompasión pobrecito
el viudo el eco de la risa de mar y me
mete doy fe si me pone en mi lugar
estúpido estás vivo que te quejas
la oigo cuando el otro mocoso el muy
hijo de su madre alguien le dice ay qué
lindo nene decime y tu mamá mamá se
murió
si se murió tienes un caramelo
literalmente
literalmente oigo la risa de la madre
cuando pasan cosas como como
sebastián en ted resuena en carcajadas
de ultratumba y si no obstante acá estoy
acepte el desafío porque me siento
vocero de su enseñanza su mensaje
qué cuál sería en definitiva
aprovecharemos que se twitea
y dejemos que sea ella misma o su propia
palabra que nos lo diga
preguntémosle de mari que no quisiste
decir que te gustaría habernos enseñado
marín
[Aplausos]
les pido perdón sólo traté de ponerme en
serio pero con esta mina no se puede
igual firma al pie que quede claro yo
acá no viene enseñar nada ni ahí que
pretendo yo venir a decirles a ustedes
cómo se tienen que morir por favor todos
ustedes todos mueran sé cómo [ __ ] se
les cante si le viene a decir eso que
cuando el esto que si quieren se pueden
morir haciendo lo que [ __ ] se les
cante se puede soy testigo
ojalá no lo fuera ojalá no tuviera tu
historia para contar pero la tengo y
como esto me trajeron y ustedes me
escucharon la conté y ahora nippur va a
tener una mamá
un poquito más legendaria que más puedo
decir gracias
[Aplausos]